elle nous sommes de retour sur facebook
france 3 centre val de loire au festival
terres du son un je le rappelle c'est au
sud de tours au domaine de candé dans la
commune de mont et à présent nous allons
voyager direction l'australie et ses
belles plages de sable fin avec ça vous
avez reconnu c'est moche merci d'être
avec nous nous faire voyager 1 sur
france 3 centre val de loire j'évoque
l'australie car votre musique
électronique est très influencé par
cette culture par la chillwave un genre
musical que vous avez découvert qu'au
bon déjà c'est j'écoute et des groupes
via saint-claude et coop qui était bas
qui venait en fait du monde entier un
peu de partout et puis j'ai fait je me
suis rendu compte que j'écoutais
beaucoup de grosses très bien et qui
faisait une joie de musique mélange
entre de la pop et d'électronique
et puis en me renseignant église et
enfin gens me disaient ben en fait nous
on fait de la chillwave et donc je suis
un peu renseigné sur le genre de le
courant en fait ça vient des états unis
à la base donc c'est c'est scellier
entre la surf music le surf la nature et
tout ce qui est ambiante en fait et
mélanger sada pop électronique et les
autres a vraiment développé en fait un
ils sont un peu approprié le terme et
j'ai découvert comme plein de pas mal de
groupes en fait qu'ils sont pas
populaires en france ils sont pas très
connus comme la mare torah qui fonda
qu'il faut se soucier de musique et ce
qui est marrant c'est que dans ma
chambre je composais à peu près la même
chose mais sans savoir ce que je faisais
enfin je me pose pas de questions sur le
genre en fait surtout que c'est un
mélange de deux pleins fluence de rock
de sonorités exotiques de des x 2
je veux dire de beatmaking beaucoup plus
hip hop aussi
donc en fait il ya ya c'est un mélange
de tout ça et vous étiez quand même dans
une ambiance riviera parce que vous êtes
originaire de la côte d'azur de nice ça
fortement aussi contribué on va dire à
cette ambiance qui évidemment nous donne
un air de vacances en permanence je vais
pas faire cliché mais en fait pas du
tout je crois enfin c'est pas à nice qui
m'a donné en fait c'est ses idées c'est
surtout parce que j'ai commencé à
voyager et en fait c'est venu surtout de
mes voyages en fait c'est quand je
partais justement nice et quand je
revenais alice j'avais mon studio et du
coup tout ce que j'avais dans la tête
que j'avais pris ailleurs et ben j'avais
mon chez moi mon petit studio dans
lequel je pouvais bas enregistré avec
clavier mais mes guitares et tout ça et
c'est comme ça qu'est né en fait toute
cette musique après voilà je vais dire
que c'est plus influencé par le voyage
que non on peut voyager en écoutant vos
musiques tout en étant sur la french
riviera mômes c'est votre nom de scène
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
même en fait c'est un surnom comme
donner surtout quand j'étais plus jeune
parce qu'on me disait l'arrêt de faire
le mort quand j'étais en train de faire
de la musique et des fois je m'arrêtais
pas parce qu'il ya ce truc euphorique
des fois qu'on fait la musique on oublie
tout ce qui se passe autour
comme un gosse aussi ça vient de là en
fait et en fait j'ai gardé le surnom
parce que tout simplement parce que je
me suis pas pris la tête je me suis dit
bon on m'appelle comme ça vous avez
appris à composer de la musique
électrique parce que vous avez quand
même une formation plus classique à
l'origine ben en fait c'est ultra lié
quoi le classique apporte les meilleures
bases du monde pour faire de la musique
et du coup je fais j'ai que je faisais
un petit peu jazz aussi et j'ai commencé
à toucher
j'ai appris la guitare en fait par moi
même j'ai commencé à toucher à la basse
la batterie tout ça est et en touchant
un petit peu à touba
mon but c'était vraiment de composer des
musiques à part entière et du coup les
synthés analogiques sont venus en fait
bien sûr sur mon chemin avec avec les
séquenceurs comme bolton et enfin les
synthés analogiques saintais numérique
en faire un tous en fait tout ce qui
concerne la production vraiment
production musique de a à z un conte
polar et al le mix aussi parce que c'est
des métiers complètement différents mais
tout va intéresser et surtout j'ai
beaucoup bossé en fait pour pour pouvoir
tout faire seul parce que c'est c'est
quand même
bah c'est pour moi c'était une fierté
aussi d'y arriver qu'est ce qu'il ya
comme des dj qui vous ont influencé
ah oui complètement il y en a bah ça
dépend enfin il ya eu beaucoup de
périodes différentes
je crois que les premiers gas electric
que j'écoutais c'était des anglais de
chez warp voir breakers bibio bas
c'était vraiment les premiers en fait
qui faisait de la musique un peu mélangé
acoustique électronique plutôt ambiante
et puis après j'ai écouté pas mal de hip
hop aussi thibault rjd2 beaucoup de rap
aussi les productions de rap parce que
ça j'adorais ça et aussi la french touch
quoi donc la fin points 0,2 point à 0,3
tout août à french touch en fait jusqu'à
jusqu'à aujourd'hui est ce qu'il y a
en fait voilà après ça a créé un genre
de mélange entre salade she wolf que
j'écoutais aussi quel moment de la
journée vous sentez le mieux pour
proposer voix c'est le matin à fond en
fait je suis le matin en général je me
lève je suis frais je pense qu'à ça où
généralement j'ai bien dormi une bonne
musique alors votre quart est toute
récente à parce que quand lucas pu vous
découvert seulement en 2015 avec le
morceau aloi qu'on a coûté au début de
cette interview
extrait de votre premier album qui est
sorti fin 2016 c'est assez récent ce
morceau est chanté par l'australienne de
mary jane qu'ils étaient lorsque nous
ici on ne la connaît pas bah vous
devriez la connaître c'est une super
artistes en fête et je les ai rencontrés
en fait sur instagram
en gros je post est moins souvent des
sons de ce que je faisais elle m'a
envoyé un message privé et là je dis
j'avais une j'avais l'instrumental daloa
en fait sans la voix et je vous en fait
marcher déjà cette musique en live je
voyais très bien que les jambes à
accrocher grave ça dans ses appartements
là et c'est très rare en france de faire
danser un public quand ils connaissent
pas une musique sur ce style là en plus
qui n'existait pas vraiment bas sur les
radios on n'entendait pas vraiment c'est
son nom était tout ça et je voulais pas
sortir jusqu'à ce que je tombe sur
mérine qui est une super artiste qui a
une super voix et du coup on a posé
dessus elle a posé une a cappella que
j'ai retouché en fait par la suite et
puis c'est devenu aloi en fait ça je
vais rencontrer en personne j'imagine
pas fait ça virtuellement par écran
interposé
non en fait on s'est dit qu'à partir du
moment où ça commence à marcher on s'est
rencontré à paris avant que je parte en
australie et c'est marrant parce que
elle elle était en europe pour un voyage
bat vraiment voyage pendant un an fait
pour découvrir l'europe et moi j'allais
partir le mois d'après
en australie du coup donc la traque
était sorti en septembre en septembre
2015 et en rouge parti en octobre en
fait en australie donc c'était vraiment
au moment où dans ma tête tout était en
ébullition et la musique a commencé à
passer en radio bien plus tard en fait
peut-être six mois après où un après
vous vous êtes parti donc en australie
pour enregistrer votre album alors dans
des conditions assez particulières
racontez moi c'est plutôt étonnant
d'enregistrer un album de cette manière
ouais en fait c'est pas mon truc ça a
toujours été de faire d'abus que ça
vient de mettre des voyages je me suis
dit pourquoi pas carrément faire une
musique nomade est composée sur le
moment en fait de partout pour pas
perdre une miette d'authenticité en fait
sur sur mes morceaux
donc je suis parti en australie j'ai
acheté un van grâce à mes économies que
j'avais fait pendant quelques années et
j'ai fait un homme suis dedans donc
vraiment quelque chose de très modestes
avec des moyens limités enfin
normalement des moyens dit vraiment
limité pour créer un album est donc
j'avais deux enceintes de monitoring un
clavier des petits instruments des
petites percuté mon défi c'était de
créer un album sur les routes
australiennes faire le tour de
l'australie et faire des rencontres là
bas parce que j'ai pas mal de chanteur
sur cet album de dons mérine un axe
apple dylan me nice monaco c'est
vraiment des artistes australiens avec
qui j'ai voulu partager cet album qui
s'appelle panorama qui est sorti en
novembre dernier et puis ça a été un
de défi relevé c'est ça aussi
justement en fait vous faites partie de
la nouvelle génération des dj s qu'en
réalisant votre album de cette manière
il ya un message que vous vouliez faire
passer en dix ans on a plus besoin d
dans un grand studio maintenant on peut
enregistrer un album n'importe où
n'importe quand c'est plus est c'est
plus le fait garder les choses
authentiques c'est vraiment important et
aujourd'hui il y a
il ya beaucoup d' image a beaucoup de
cas mais a beaucoup de de mauvaises
informations en fait de partout et c'est
vraiment quelque chose que j'essaie de
garder
après il ya que j'essaye de dégager à
travers vos projets en fait c'est que
c'est un projet vraiment réel à taille
humaine et ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose que je défends parce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut facilement bas se
tromper on peut croire que certains
artistes créent leur musique alors
qu'aujourd'hui le monde de la musique
c'est la moitié des artistes qui
composent pas leur musique
donc c'est beaucoup d'interprètes et ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est ben
voilà que je défends un petit peu parce
que les gens ils ont envie de voir
quelqu'un d'authentiqué sur scène ils
ont envie d'écouter de la musique bat
enfin les vrais mélomanes je veux dire
les gens qui vivent pour ça en tout cas
ils ont envie de ils ont envie de ça
donc je fais partie de voulez vraiment
être ambassadeur de la vraie musique
incarner évidemment sur scène comme ce
soir pour ce festival terres du son
bien sûr tout le reste c'est juste que
par les panoramas c'est le nom de votre
album c'est aussi le nom de votre
tournée vous fait beaucoup de festivals
cet été pourquoi l'avoir appelée
panorama saab a finalement balayé le
large spectre de votre univers musical
ça vient de là ouais carrément basse et
surtout que l'australie c'est vraiment
plein de panoramas différence est que
quand on passe d'un décor à lot c'est un
pays énorme c'est pas des cultures qui
change aussi parce que en australie a
énormément de d'étrangers donc j'ai
rencontré beaucoup beaucoup de voyageurs
du monde en titre et qui étaient là bas
et ça plus les émotions
en fait j'ai cherché un nom qui était
universel comprendre voilà un anglais un
anglais on importe qui peut comprendre
c'est vraiment vous avez vraiment pour
objectif d'avoir une carrière
internationale donc du coup d'utiliser
tout de suite
des termes qui sont compréhensibles par
tous c'est ça c'est ça c'est vraiment le
sait sera je l'espère pour moi la
prochaine étape
qu'est ce que ça fait justement de
passer d'un mix à la maison à un mix
devant des milliers de personnes comme
ce soir
ben c'est beaucoup de travail beaucoup
d'organisation et il ya un truc super
cool dans le live c'est la balle
partagent surtout avec le public parce
que on s'étonne et on prend beaucoup de
du public en fait ça donne de l'espoir
ça ça donne envie de faire de la musique
encore plus faim je veux dire ça donne
des idées pour transporter les gens et
bah c'est pas du tout enfin c'est pas du
tout le même métier
en fait ces deux choses complètement
différentes après un maul j'ai pas
vraiment de préférence je crois que je
préfère le studio je préfère fond
au-dessus diot ou la composition
vraiment le métier de composition c'est
ce que j'aime le plus
après le live je me des chaînes je
m'éclate quoi vous imaginez votre
présence sur scène parce que c'est vrai
quand on s'est dit on va avoir de la
musique électro avec un dj ronde à ses
platines il est derrière et voilà mais
vous conservez comment finalement ce
show déjà je suis pas dj en fait c'est à
la base j'étais procureur je suis
producteur de musique dans ma vie dans
une case dj parce que ben j'étais pas un
live band mais en vrai en live et j'ai
d'un clavier j'ai des percussions
j'aimais guitare j'ai trois guitares
j'ai déjà tout un système au tour qui
est dix fois plus aboutie en fait qu'un
set dj où il ya juste deux platines et
vous préférez qu'on vous qualifie de
musiciens c'est plus chaud de musique
électro on peut le qualifier comme ça ce
soir
merci même d'avoir été avec nous sur
france 3 centre val de loire
ce sera ce soir assez tard d'ailleurs ce
concert aux alentours de minuit jusqu'à
1h15 parce que c'est vrai qu'on aime
danser sur des rythmes comme ça jusqu'au
bout de la nuit
merci d'avoir été avec nous excellent
concert et belle tournée estivale
on va se retrouver un peu plus tard avec
un air de famille sur france 3 centre
ville loin pour ce festival terres du
son qui s'achève ce soir